I'm Patrick Lee David your host evalute
a man and two weeks ago was on a flight
back from Dallas and I got a call from
someone who runs a business and he
called me says Patrick you know what I'm
struggling I said what's that he said
man how can I find a loyal people that
stay with me for years instead of
constantly training people putting all
these hours into him and I lose them to
another person or they become my
competition so that's a great question I
don't have an answer for him at that
time I said give me a few hours I took
the entire flight and I wrote four pages
of notes and 17 different ways to create
loyalty and I'm going to give you my
points today based on books as well so
if each specific point I make to you
most of them will have a book to go
reference for you to know how to create
a loyalty in your organization but with
that being said I also want to show you
this you know I for many years II of
being a CEO of a company I've had a
traditional office executive office
which is most like a Oval Office is what
it was as I got to change the whole
thing gut because I'm so sick and tired
of sitting down and all these fancy desk
I got to change the whole thing up and I
love to read and I want to create a
bookshelf that's very creative and so we
have this bookshelf that says read and I
thought it was only going to cost a few
thousand dollars to make it cost a lot
of money we had a person that had to
come and customize the whole thing so
bookshelf reading is what we put up and
I got my 500 something books here I got
another thousand books at the house I'm
an avid reader that I've been reading
all my life since twenty one years old
after I got out of the military so
here's a makeover to the office let's
get right into it let's get right into
it I'm actually very excited about the
subject so while olt right
anytime somebody asks you you know why
am i losing so many people there's
always things like as if the problem is
on the people not being loyal right
there's no more loyal people nowadays
there's there's no more there's so many
these Millennials you know they're so
distracted and then there's younger
generation they they're not like us
because we were loyal and we stuck
around and we did one thing
we did this and it's always this
generation and by the when you start
saying statements like that you know
what's happening to you
Time magazine did an article talking
about the Millennials it's the me me me
generation it's a great cover I'm sure
you've seen it before and in the end is
explaining the millennial generation
they're like this they're all about
Instagram they're all about this robot
and antennae says if you keep saying the
new generation is lazy they've changed
or this their that all it means is you
are getting older my long sunny it's
very interesting when I read us it what
a great article but let me get right
into it so how do you create an
environment where people want to be
loyal and stay with you forever I got 72
points point number one first thing very
important number one it's very very
important don't be afraid of losing
people you cannot be afraid of losing
people you see when you build your
business a lot of time your solar you're
by yourself and you feel like you want
to run it me what if somebody that's
gonna help you grow the business as well
you know it's almost like that one video
that was done on TEDx it was a five
minute video and it shows the guy that's
dancing you know he's doing his own
thing and he was by himself an X you
know another guy shows up and another
guy shows up and he says in the TEDx
speaker says you always want that first
idiot that believes in you right that's
the reference she made but it's not
really an idiot it's somebody that says
I believe in you you see the book that
I'll highlight with that point don't be
afraid of losing people
it is Lincoln on leadership Clinton call
this his Bible Time magazine says
Clinton's private bible about how to
govern and in the book one of the
chapters he talks about keep searching
until you find your grant and a lot of
times people want to make their grant he
says until you find your grant you got
to find your grant but in order to find
your grant you can't be afraid of losing
people
he put McClellan as a general the army
and he got with him he found another
person other person and he kept going
through their organization and he found
this crazy general was you know came up
and he's granting you know he wouldn't
talk to him all the time you wouldn't
communicate with him all this time but
every time he talked to me wonder war he
was about every single time so if he had
the mindset of trying to retain every
single soldier and you know not hurt
their feelings and I can't have
McClellan be upset with me and
because I've got to keep everybody happy
he would have never won the war he would
have never done what he did and it would
be not so many books being written about
him as the greatest president we ever
had in the history of America 16
president but you can't be friend of
losing people if you want to have a
royal involvement or number two you got
to be true to your cause he had a cause
you got to have a cause someone asked me
Patrick I was at a convention last week
we're doing an award ceremony I'm giving
a closing talk on Friday you can
actually click on the link below to
watch the talk I gave in front of 1,500
agents of ours and I talked about what
got me fired up about starting a
business and why the company's crusade
the cause is in my belly and the crusade
the guy said Patrick you got up and he
said saving America by bringing back the
free enterprise system and hope to
American families man what do you think
I can come out with you get people
excited and the question I was
flabbergasted by the question as if a
person comes out with a cause to keep
people as if it's a manipulative way to
keep people motivated if you really
don't have a cause that's meaningful to
you people will read it if your causes
to get people to fall into this idea as
if something going to happen people will
know about it six months 12 months 24
months later if you don't talk about it
24/7 it's really not you so how does
somebody find your cause I wrote a book
called 25 laws for doing the impossible
that's been translated in five different
languages Polish Russian Romanian
simplified Chinese in English and in
there I talked about how to identify
your own cause you got to find your
cause that fires you up a book called
the leaderless revolution it should be
somewhere here was written by a British
diplomat leaderless revolution it's
written by British diplomat he said the
way you find your own revolution the way
you find your cause you got to find out
three things what do you love what you
hate them what bothers you when you
write them what you hate what you love
and what bothers you you eventually come
out come up with an answer where you say
this is what fires me up this is what
gets me going to a whole different level
but you got to find out those three
elements of what you love what you hate
and what bothers you and about
twenty-five laws for doing the
impossible healthy others will do
thinkers on the bottom as well for you
to find third point leaders don't like
to have their butts kissed let me
explain to you a point you you remember
back in high school what you think about
the prettiest girl in high school who
was the prettiest girl in your high
school I want you to think about her
name now here's what I want you to think
about generally the prettiest girl in
high school um either dates a very very
nice guy who she dumps or she dates a a
bad boy who he dumps her okay and they
both have their own consequences let me
explain to what I mean by that when a
pretty girl dates a good guy the guy
says things like oh my I love you so
much you're so pretty
into his mom mom this is my wife I love
her she's so look at her hair she's
soaked I love her toes you know the way
she walks mom she's my wife she's great
and you know your mom's a convict she
scrolls about to break up with you
before doing you don't get you're acting
by the way all her gods fellas you know
what's happened to us that we all got a
heart broken at one point and then she
says I can take this anymore and she
wants to go to somewhere where a guy's
saying look you either want to date me
or you don't because I have choices and
she wants to date the bad boy right so
what is the right person is it being the
person that's always there always
everything or is it the guy just like if
you don't want I can go to another girl
type of mentality here's what I realized
leaders don't want either they want you
to be real with them right in the middle
tell them what's on your mind but tell
them in the right way that you respect
them and speak with them but don't
always go out and try to be so awesome
perfect everything with them it's not
going to happen don't kiss their but
leave them is what you need to do that's
how you create loyalty pointer before
you don't earn loyalty by doing
everything for them let me explain what
I mean by doing everything for that a
lot of times I'll go to a sales
organization I'll notice that the leader
does have any leader so you may have 50
people in the room that his sales forces
there but there's no leaders in the room
everybody is lower-level people I said
why is that and generally it's because
he's doing everything for everybody so
he's so concerned of keeping everybody
that when he gets a Jordan or Kobe or
jobs of his organization that comes to
him I can't work
like this he's not spending enough time
with me he wants to please everybody I
want his time give me 90 percent every
time because I want to work with you and
he wants to spread this time equally
with everybody she because an
overachiever if you want his loyalty he
wants you to know he wants to know that
you've done stuff with your life before
you're successful and he wants you to
give him direction you want you to give
him coaching he wants you to challenge
him and if he wants to go do it himself
without your help because it's important
for him to know that he can do it on his
own with your coaching helping a process
issues but he went and did it himself if
he doesn't he wasn't a leader in the
first place you were wasting your time
dysentery time building him okay so
point over for you don't know loyalty by
doing everything for them number five
they need to see you in the game they
need to see you in the game running what
does that mean well if you're working
from home and you want to hold everybody
accountable from home or from the golf
course six days a week and you say well
I can't believe they're not loyal to me
and you're constantly criticizing
because you don't see what they're doing
on a daily basis working you're not
lifting them up you're not recognizing
them and you're not coming to work
yourself five six days a week you're not
going to have a lot of loyalty and
there's this contradiction in business
where you know someone told me sell
Patrick you know I worked so hard and
I'm making a few million dollars a year
and I earned it and and and I can show
you how to do the same but I want to
golf six days a week and I don't need to
come to the office and I said you're
right but you're people also don't have
to be loyal to you forever because it's
called free market capitalism and if you
don't do it right you're gonna lose your
person to somebody else and if you look
at companies Northern California hey
when Yahoo came out they thought they
made it Yahoo lost their talent to
Google Google doesn't lose a lot of
engineers there lose a lot of engineers
because Google's vision and causes so
big they're not afraid of losing talent
that they keep getting good people there
because they have their big thinkers
right but can you imagine the founders
of Google started golf in six days so we
can then show up to work and they just
say guys keep searching keep you know
pay-per-click keep doing this you guys
are doing a great job and in golf six
days but there's nowhere you do that I
was in Zappos last week headquarters I
got a tour of Zappos and I we took our
staff to get a private tour of Zappos
had a great very good Town shout out to
those guys they do a very good job with
it
and our tour guide was the what was her
name - equestrian our tour guides name
was something about a question anyways
we had a great time with the right and
as we're walking regular we're doing a
tour we walk past Tony Hsieh then we go
to a place this CEO the company you know
one of the owners of the company is
sitting right there working right next
to us hey how you doing I spoke to my
pop up a good go middle today they're
working that creates an environment
where people want to be loyal to the
brand of Zappos because they see you in
the game - two - one royalty from people
you not being in the game it's it's it's
very foolish to believe that it's just
not possible it's not going to happen
number six royalty gets stronger during
times of friction I see a lot of times
you know I get a call in home like I
took him to a very bad fight an argument
it was terrible he was screaming I was
screaming I can't believe he said this
to me and I think he's gonna leave it I
don't think he's gonna be here with us
for too long and this totally was a bad
thing and I said listen that was a great
thing that happened what do you mean
he's gonna quit tomorrow no he's not
he's gonna leave no he's nice my best
he's not why leaders know there's
friction that the process of making a
sausage is very ugly but the final
product tastes good friction is a part
of it knowing how to handle friction is
the real challenge the book I recommend
for that is called great business teams
by Howard Guttman I hired Howard Guttman
is from New York real real good
personality guy to come in a deal with a
few of our guys and we had a whole
morning afternoon session and Q&A and we
went through confrontation how does
conflicts work how to get better at
conflicts etc etc and eventually you
realize that it's not necessarily that a
team doesn't need to have a environment
that's friction free it's you need to
work on how to handle conflicts rather
than creating a conflict free
environment a conflict free environment
generally is not growing it's not
exploding if there needs to be conflict
in that environment point number seven
what number seven is is talking behind
your leaders back - I love talking
behind my ears
I love saying things behind the leaders
back I love it and they love it too by
the way they love it they can't get
enough of it and I think sometimes
leaders don't do enough of a job of
talking behind people's back you got to
do more of it it's constant think of
talking down he was like now what am I
talking about I'm not talking about
talking negatively about people spend
behind people's back I'm talking about
you creating positive rumors about them
I'm talking about you saying great
things behind our back without them
being everybody loves it when you say
good things when everybody is there but
believe it or not people love it more
when you talk behind people's back when
nobody else is there it's gotta be a
natural thing you do they love hearing
rumors say here that I was sitting down
with bother you only what he was saying
about you say you're the hardest working
guy in the office and he can count on
you because you always go out there bill
I mean you're a great leader you're your
tough guy you you work hard oh he said
that he said I think sometimes leaders
don't do know you don't do enough of a
job of talking behind leaders back and
there needs to be more of that taking
place with the people that you're
leading to can see talk behind their
back
point number eight point on rape is
creating an environment where everyone
calls each other out if you have an
environment where everybody is too
politically correct and everyone's
trying to make everybody happy
it's not gonna be a good environment to
be around it's gotta be an environment
where everybody is calling each other I
went to an office someone showed up late
who's I said it wasn't a big deal in a
beanie and a leader speaking you're okay
with that yes no one said anything yes
you to come are you to concern about
please on somebody and point number one
was what don't be afraid of losing
people if you are you're not going to be
retaining too many people you need to
have a place where it's an environment
where everybody calls each other out if
there's a code and people call each
other out that environment holds
everybody accountable anyways that's the
first eight points I got nine more
points to go with you in part two if you
haven't subscribed to this channel be
sure to subscribe to the channel and
then go on to part two this video